Fatima's and Inge is proud of her father
and his vocal opposition to yo-yo
jammies 23 year rule a year ago solos
and Inge led a demonstration against
Jamie's dictatorship he was carted away
by security forces and later killed we
had a dictator and he wouldn't let
anybody expressio yo-yo
whatever you feel without just doing
anything to you so he knew what was
going to happen to him but he did it for
Gambia and Gambians and like he has
always been saying if he was supposed to
be the sacrificial lamb for Gambia to be
free he was going to do it and that's
what he did on that day it's now up to
the High Court in The Gambia to
determine who killed Zola's ending the
hearing has been postponed supposedly
because of errors in the paperwork
tensions are high as the accused among
them the former head of the secret
police are taken to court they have got
to be rocking in town and I said it
a scuffle breaks out between the victims
relatives and those of the accused I
can't take it in my hands but then that
is my wish I wish I could just do to him
what he did to my father really because
it's it's just so painful to see
somebody whose mother your father in
broad daylight
standing alive you know but then that's
what we have to do as decent people we
have to be decent than them so let
justice be served for 22 years a huge
number of crimes and human rights abuses
were committed under the watch of former
autocrat hiya Jamie how to come to terms
with the past is one of the key
challenges of the new government
president Adama Barrow has already said
that he likes the idea of a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission but he is yet
to be more precise about it however one
thing is clear the courts and the
judicial system are already overwhelmed
the Gambia's Chief Justice has
complained that the Supreme Court is
short of judges and hasn't convened in
almost two years despite a long backlog
of unresolved cases in addition the
number of charges against ex-president
Jame s former backers is expected to
rise dramatically the High Court which
is supposed to deal with these many of
these cases is seriously understaffed at
the moment it's probably at a just about
25 percent of its full strength and we
are very busy now trying to recruit
judges in order to be able to get the
high court fully operational
Fatima's anding is convinced the new
Gambia will overcome these obstacles and
deal with the crimes of the old regime
she wants to look to the future and
start a foundation in her father's
memory
if you leave the name the foundation has
to do with all the things that he lived
for things that he wanted to see the
gambia have that his freedom that his
equality is like what he was advocating
for electoral reforms anything good that
he died for and he lived for we want to
make sure we continue that freedom has
been a long time coming for Gambians
they believe their country has a long
road of challenges following the end of
Yaya Jamie's dictatorship